[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle émission du 7-8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 21 avril le zoo de
thoiry vers plus d'écologie le parc
vient de lancer la construction d'une
usine de méthanisation objectif
exploiter les déchets organiques et
notamment le fumier animal pour produire
ensuite du gaz ce processus devrait
profiter à 2000 foyers et jérôme
champetier de ribes est notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission il est depuis
quelques semaines le nouveau président
du secours catholique dans les yvelines
nous évoquerons avec lui sa fonction est
le rôle de l'association dans le
département enfin dans le reste de
l'actualité nous reviendrons sur la
semaine du handicap elle en cours et la
ville de coignières qui a présenté à
cette semaine à ses habitants les
grandes orientations de son futur plu le
plan local d'urbanisme
c'est une première pour un zoo en france
le parc de thoiry a débuté
officiellement la construction d'une
unité de méthanisation comprenait à un
procédé biologique qui a pour but de
valoriser les matières organiques du
parc et de ses alentours pour produire
ensuite du gaz et du fertilisant plus
d'explications avec ce sujet de mélanie
poker et patrick jacques de dixmude une
première pierre symbolique la conclusion
d'un projet de plus de 8 ans est une
première pour un parc zoologique touahri
se lance dans la biométhanisation
on prend les déchets on les met dans ce
qui s'appelle le digesteur parce qu'en
fait les déchets sont digérés par des
bactéries thermophile la température
monte à 55 degrés ce qui en fait
éliminer les mauvaises bactéries et
quand cette matière est ainsi transformé
donc pendant que les bactéries gerbe et
elle ça fermente on à la production de
méthane qui est ensuite transformé en
gaz pour chauffer les bâtiments ou pour
faire fonctionner des véhicules les
déchets le fumier animale les déchets
verts ou encore des fruits et légumes
invendus le château le parc mais aussi
huit autres communes dont plaisir en
bénéficieront lusine de biométhane
alimentera près de deux mille foyers ont
partenariat
grdf elle questionne cette démarche en
fait le modèle énergétique actuelle et
de demain c'est vraiment la tradition
énergétique au sens propre du terme
puisque on est sur du gaz qui est
produit localement à partir de déchets
on est sur l'économie circulaire et il
s'agit là donc d'une énergie
renouvelable chaque année les animaux du
parc produisent 400 tonnes de fumier
en plus du gaz l'usiné produira plus de
dix mille tonnes de fertilisants par an
et on poursuit cette émission avec notre
invité fil rouge jérôme champetier de
ribes bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes depuis
le 1er mars le nouveau président de
l'antenne locale du secours catholique
une nouvelle fonction pour vous avant
vous avez travaillé je crois dans le btp
vous êtes toujours en activité
professionnelle un petit peu en ce
moment expliquez nous comment on passe
du btp à la présidence du secours
catholique
comment s'est passé le processus
complètement alors le btp en fait c'est
le début de ma carrière avait quinze
premières années où j'ai eu la chance de
construire des grands chantiers et donc
de travailler sur des gros objets avec
beaucoup de monde et donc j ai j'ai
développé le goût du concert ensemble et
puis ç'a duré 15 ans et puis après il ya
eu 25 20 ans une bonne vingtaine
d'années où je suis consultant dans
l'accompagnement le coaching dirigeants
et puis tout ce qui tourne autour de la
dynamique collective comment créer une
dynamique avec des gens autour d'une
mission que ce genre d'entreprise dans
des hôpitaux
donc j'ai un lien entre le coaching on
va dire votre façon d'appréhender votre
métier de consultant et puis la
présidence tout à fait et donc arrivant
à l'âge de la retraite je me suis dit
comment valoriser toute cette expérience
de dynamique collective et le sucre
catholique m'a appelé à ce moment là
pour effectivement prendre la présidence
sur les yvelines et donc j'y vois là une
nouvelle occasion de donner tout mon
expertise moi-même dans la dynamique au
service d'une cause qui était une cause
à la fois humaines d'aller auprès des
plus pauvres des personnes en précarité
est aussi spirituellement au sein du
secours catholique en lien avec l'église
d'accord donc cesser le secours
catholique est venu vous voir
c'est pas une démarche personnelle on
est venu vous voir que vous êtes dit
alors je l'imaginé pas j'imaginais
continuer ma vie professionnelle comme
vous l'avez mentionné valeurs que j'ai
quand même des encore des clients et je
suis passionnée par mon travail
créer de l'énergie collective dans une
entreprise ou dans un hôpital mais bon
c'est vrai qu'on est venu me chercher et
je trouvais que cette proposition était
un très beau cadeau qui m'étais fait de
pouvoir donner encore de beaucoup de mes
compétences et de mon énergie à une
cause qui est belle alors je suis un
connaît le secours catholique depuis
longtemps parce que je suis face à
deurle à deux voix là et je crois bien
sûr ce ce besoin et cette nécessité de
partager mais je n'avais pas encore
rencontré tout ce monde du bénévolat et
que je découvre en ce moment un nouveau
président ça ça vient avec sa nouvelle
pâte aussi ça vient avec une vous
parliez de dynamique est ce que vous
vous inscrivez dans l'est dans les yeux
dans les pas de votre prédécesseur ou
alors voulait peut-être emprunter un
nouveau chemin si je fume tafer le
secours catholique mais c'est alors à la
fois c'est une continuité c'est que on
sent que hervé s'est servi de ce
manuscrit que vous que vous avez votre
climat qui m'a appelé et donc je une
bonne relation d'amitié et j'admire et
je salue tous tout le travail qu'il a
fait avec toutes les équipes depuis
longtemps il est resté six ans je crois
la l'exercice en voilà il a fait 6 ans
dont une partie de preuves de la partie
de la régionale et s'est occupé aussi
pendant trois ans de la région ile de
france donc il a particulièrement
travaillé sur la fracture territoriale
en en ile de france
et puis voilà la voiture d'inflexion
parce que je suis là je suis différent
de lui que je mettrais sans doute
mon attention sur d'autres points que je
m'a dit ma dynamique relationnelle
managériales et différentes voilà mais
vous découvrez votre nouveau rôle de
président les 2000 bénévoles sur le
département des lycées une vraie
structure important dans le département
comment voix vous va le costume
aujourd'hui vous êtes bien dedans oui
évidemment une nouvelle je suis très
heureux très heureux alors je découvre
beaucoup de gens je découvre les équipes
je vais j'ai commencé à m'immerger dans
l'accueil de jour de versailles donc jeu
pendant les premiers mois avant même de
rentrer dans fonction je suis allé
travailler tous les jeudis à l'accueil
de jour pour accueillir ces personnes
qui sont à la rue qui viennent se
réconforter trouver du lien à l'accueil
de jour et puis ben voilà maintenant je
découvre un peu tout et toutes les
entités les équipes avec ce qu'elle
apporte de soutien soutien scolaire les
migrants voilà enfin je découvre toutes
les facettes du secours catholique en
yvelines justement est-ce qu'un mot sur
ses pattes le fa7 l'aérés expliquer un
peu ce qu'est le secours catholique dans
dans le département des yvelines votre
but c'est d'aider et soutenir
accompagner les plus fragiles dans dans
tous les domaines qu'ils sont tout à
fait tout à fait ces voix-là aider notre
orientation nationale et de lutter
contre la pauvreté avec les personnes
quittent un peu l'assistance que qui
étaient bonnes pour nantes pendant un
temps de donner aux personnes là on
on veut les aider elle même à trouver
leur avenir le chemin de leur avenir
donc on est dans une perspective plus
d'accompagnement auprès des pauvres
alors c'est effectivement accompagné sur
des aspects logement quand on parle d'
accompagner pour sur l'aspect logement
c'est quel type d'action on aide à faire
des formulaires par exemple oui
effectivement tout ce qui est au delà de
votre vélo pour essayer de trouver des
logements et à effectuer des gens qui
sont logés à l'hôtel on en a sur le
secteur attrape en particulier et donc
on va soutenir ces gens qui sont logés
dans des conditions quand même
extrêmement spartiates pour les aider
dans les transports pour les aider dans
la scolarité de leurs enfants pour les
aider dans les cuisines puisque souvent
dans les hôtels ils n'ont pas le moyen
de de cuisiner eux-mêmes et voilà et
puis principalement ont fait du lien
c'est avec ces personnes là on les
réunit on est en lien avec elles de
manière accessible manque principal
c'est le lien c'est discuter simplement
avoir une discussion avec est reconnue
est reconnu comme quelqu'un d'important
et que malgré les conditions difficiles
dans lesquelles vivent elles sont
importantes elles ont une place même si
elles sont en situation irrégulière
voilà le secours catholique accueille
toute personne sans aucune condition de
religion de culture voilà nous sommes
catholiques mais ouvert à toutes
personnes
alors vous avez accompagné récemment
14000 personnes sur sur annoncé le bilan
je crois 2015 2016 sur le département
des yvelines dit nous on y sur un
département quand même connu pour être
assis riche pourtant 14 8 personnes ça
prouve qu'il ya un vrai besoin sur le
département comment on peut expliquer ce
décalage entre l'accompagnement de 14000
personnes et pourtant le deuxième
département le plus riche de france
passe cellier un peu à cette notion de
fracture territoriale ou que c'est pas
parce qu'un département est riche que
tout le monde est riche et donc quand on
regarde les dix communes les plus les
moins riches ont peut-on dire de notre
département et dont on sait à peu près
où elles sont eh bien on y voit que dans
ces communes là on dit concentre une
grande partie de la pauvreté de la
précarité c'est à dire que beaucoup de
communes sont riches mais ensemble de
communes sont extrêmement concentrés
tous les facteurs de plus de pauvreté de
précarité c'est à dire isolement le
chômage
voilà et donc on va des enjeux que nous
avons là pour les années qui viennent ça
va être effectivement d'arriver à
inverser cette courbe qui fait que les
plus riches s'éloigne des plus pauvres
et que cette fracture s'agrandit on peut
dire clairement que le département des
yvelines c'est un département plus riche
que les autres mais aussi plus
inégalitaire on peut tirer ce constat là
la comparaison avec les autres
en tout cas il y à des inégalités je
prends le logement social par exemple il
ya des communes qui ont à peu près 20%
de logement social et d'autres en ont 40
voilà et quand on cherche à implanter un
centre d'accès de migrants et voilà eh
bien il ya des communes qui est toujours
n 1 qui freinent non pas oui j'étais au
lit me crée sa lutte et polis voilà et
donc non pas chez nous or les
départements des yvelines qui est
effectivement assez riche et quand même
trésors de sa de ce qu'il pourrait les
moyens de aurait les moyens on va le
faire + qui sont les gens que vous aidez
j'imagine il n'y a pas un profil type
mais il ya quand même peut-être des
situations personnelles qui favorise on
va dire la pauvreté oui il ya beaucoup
de migrants gras des migrants qui sont
vraiment des débats des personnes qui
sont seules qui ont fui leur pays etc et
qui est que de nous aidons soit dans le
droit d'asile soient effectués dans
l'hébergement
il ya beaucoup aussi de femmes avec
souvent des enfants donc des familles
pauvres parental qui beaucoup de mal à
trouver un équilibre a lieu etc
voilà donc c'est ça un peu et puis après
nous avons la preuve
les personnes en précarité les personnes
de la rue qui qui viennent dans nos
accueils de jour dans les différents
lieux où on peut leur offrir un café un
lien un peu de convivialité le besoin d'
écoute ça c'est une réflexion le besoin
d'écouté d'accompagnement est ce que ça
conseil a finalement que les plus
fragiles financièrement socialement ou
est-ce que vous vous adressez aussi ou
peut-être ou aux gens ou les moyens
financiers qui ont une situation sociale
mais qui parfois peuvent être en
détresse psychologique on peut être seul
aussi vous parliez du contact quand on a
des moyens est ce que ces personnes là
aussi vous pouvez les aider ce que vous
avez vocation à les aider alors pas
spécifiquement mais ces gens là j'ai
envie de leur proposer de nous rejoindre
pour être tourné vers les autres
d'accord ce besoin de lien qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure qui tourne
autour de l' écoute voilà les coûts de
ce n'est pas forcément pour les gens les
voilà moins fragile
financièrement évidemment est donc géré
toute personne qui est acquis a envie
d'être en lien avec d'autres le riche
pauvre quand je vous ai tout à l'heure
on va tous lutter contre a proposé
ensemble contre la pauvreté ensemble
c'est bien cette notion d'être ensemble
un moment d'arrêter de penser qui est
accueillie qui est accueillant mais de
faire la fête ensemble parce que les
personnes là ces pauvres ont des
richesses en eux que nous riches nous
n'avons pas et donc voilà la vocation du
secours catholique est de créer des
ponts d'être un petit clin d'oeil
voilà et d'accompagner qui est un
deuxième temps deuil pour créer des
ponts entre effectivement ce monde des
riches qui est qui a très peur du monde
des pauvres et du monde des pauvres
qu'ils étaient très seule et très isolés
jérôme champetier de ribes rester avec
nous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et l'actualité locale a été marquée à
elancourt par une semaine spéciale sur
le handicap ateliers animations étaient
organisées pour notamment changer le
regard que portent les habitants sur les
personnes handicapées
l'un de ses temps forts avaient lieu
mercredi après-midi avec un atelier de
pâtisserie adapté à l'agora patrie
jacques de dixmude et mélanie poké envie
tu peux décent
nordine se lance dans la préparation
d'un mendiant une pâtisserie au chocolat
ils participent à un atelier culinaire
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
ouais vraiment parce que j'aime bien
dans le
ce sera ici là la cuisine et la
pâtisserie du monde au nez des chocolats
j'ai dû rêver les fondus dans le
micro-ondes et après comme je dis sortie
du monde
gili race et qu'ils se soient bien vendu
et après ils m'ont donné un maître dans
le sac de plastique et mon mini trous et
enfin j'ai commencé
à mettre dans les souliers pape j'ai une
recette simple des explications courte
l'animation est faite par l'association
élan courtoise la toque au coeur je suis
concernée par le handicapeur par ma
fille est en fait était en fauteuil
roulant et donc c'est une activité qu'on
pratique souvent à la maison donc doux
d'où l'idée en fait de créer une
association pour ce à partir avec sa
création et puis c'est vrai que je crée
aussi une petite fiche recette donc qui
vont qui leur permet de pouvoir refaire
à la maison avec les petites techniques
que j'ai donné pendant cours douze
apprentis pâtissiers se sont essayés à
la cuisine du chocolat depuis mardi à
elancourt c'est la semaine du handicap
d'autres animations sont prévues jusqu'à
samedi et justement à propos de ces
animations et pour être complet sur le
sujet un atelier des ateliers sont
prévus samedi 22 avril plus de
précisions sur le site internet de la
commune www.villepincom.net faire jérôme
champetier de ribes ce genre
d'initiative j'imagine que vous les
soutenez est-ce que vous en tant que
président aujourd'hui du secours
catholique 60 18 ans tant que citoyen
aussi est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'on change un peu notre regard sur le
handicap en france sur les personnes
pauvres aussi ça a été un sujet souvent
tabou qu'il est encore probablement
beaucoup trop selon vous est ce qu'il ya
une évolution positive tout de même je
pense qu'il ya une prise de conscience
progressive de de cette fracture et de
la façon dont on ne pourra pas vivre
éternellement avec qui va un moment on
va être confronté sur cette fracture je
suis très touché par ce reportage
puisque c'est vraiment dans la même
dynamique le handicap d'un côté la
pauvreté de l'autre c'est des gens qui
sont qui ont envie d'un souvent liées
aussi d'ailleurs
oui alors en plus souvent c'est ça ce
cumul mais il ya c'est ce besoin de
faire quelque chose ensemble plaisir de
faire de la cuisine et on sait très
proche de ce qu'on fait nous aussi et
donc là il ya besoin de rencontres 2
on voit quand on s'approche de l'autre
on a moins peur de sa différence et puis
on voit sa richesse je crois savoir
juste pour terminer notre entretien que
d'ailleurs vous cherchez des bénévoles
qui compte que souhaite devenir bénévole
au secours catholique et est le bienvenu
oui tout à fait c'est d'ailleurs à
connais pas que des personnes âgées
c'est absolument ces deux axes -ce de
rajeunir la moyenne d'âge à peu près 65
ans dans mais les nouveaux bénévoles
qu'au recrutement est âgé de 45 ans donc
il faut pas hésiter à venir au secours
catholique
alors ils font n'importe quelle action
voilà dès qu'on a un peu de temps pour
donner deux heures on peut donner une
âme et une demi journée une journée
voilà je vous ai tout le monde est bien
est vraiment le bienvenu on a besoin de
bras merci jérôme champetier de ribes
d'être venu en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le nouveau président 78 du
secours catholique merci à vous dans le
reste de l'actualité cette semaine la
ville de coignières a organisé une
réunion d'information autour de son
futur plan local d'urbanisme ce document
doit fixer les grandes orientations en
matière d'urbanisme pour les 15
prochaines années et ce alors que la
population de la ville ne cesse de
décroître les détails avec ce reportage
à quoi ressemblera coignières en 2030
comment rendre complémentaires le volet
rural et commercial de la ville
près d'une centaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour cette réunion publique et
écouter le maire a exposé ses
propositions pour l'aménagement et le
développement durable de la commune est
d'ici 15 ans coignières un peu plus de
4300 habitants devrait voir sa
population augmenter de 28%
nous devons aussi construire des
logements sur coignières c'est une une
nécessité pour que poignet revivent
également nous avons des secteurs
commerciaux intéressant nous avons un
secteur industriel également intéressant
mais il nous faut également construire
des logements parce qu'il nous faut
accueillir
les personnes qui ont un parcours
résidentiel et qui veulent rester sur
coignières pour préserver son image de
village à la campagne la majorité a
détaillé aux habitants quatre grandes
orientations et une vingtaine de points
parmi ceux ci la diversification de
l'offre de logement le renforcement de
l'attractivité commerciale ou encore
comme attrape récemment l'enfouissement
de la nationale 10 ce qui est important
là entre autres c'est sur ce préalable
de la nationale 10 cette histoire
d'enfouissement qui était dans les
cartons mais dont on pense pas que ce
serait quand même quelque chose qui soit
acté quoi comme ça moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne démarche surtout des
questions sur le
l'augmentation du nombre de logements du
fait que coignières est resté par mx est
stable depuis 40 ans la est donc aussi
sur le
l'accessibilité qui était intéressante
aussi une nouvelle réunion publique est
prévue le 5 juillet prochain
l'approbation du pmu est prévu quand
elle pour juin 2010 8 à plaisir
maintenant en 80 logements vont voir
bientôt le jour à la place de l'ancienne
gendarmerie le bâtiment vacant depuis
2004 appartenait à l'état il accueillera
désormais neuf logements les autres
seront construits sur le terrain d'un
hectare à côté du bâtiment militaire
c'est le promoteur crédit agricole
immobilier qui mènera le chantier la
livraison est prévue pour le début de
l'année 2020 il y aura à la fois 50 % de
logements sociaux
moi je préfère dire des logements aidés
puisque aujourd'hui vous savez que
énormément de population française peut
accéder aux logements sociaux surtout
les jeunes
nous avons aussi ce respect du maintien
des 25 % de logements sociaux sur
l'ensemble de la collectivité
aujourd'hui nous sommes entre 25 et 26 %
donc dans toute mise en place de
nouvelles habitat sur la collectivité
est important de gérer cette intégration
des logements sociaux pour garder notre
équilibre et 25% en sachant que nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait une mixité dans
l'habitat parce qu'aujourd'hui n'est
plus question de faire des quartiers
sociaux entièrement un autre chantier
dans l'actualité locale cette semaine et
le centre commercial parly 2 situé aux
chaînés l'un des plus vieux de france
inaugurée il ya 48 ans est en pleine
rénovation depuis 2010 maintenant après
avoir construit une sortie sur la
départementale 186 et de nouveaux
parkings la structure vient de lancer la
dernière phase de son projet une
extension avec de nouveaux magasins la
livraison est programmée pour la fin de
l'année
mélanie poké et miquel et demi d'euros
c'est le point final d'un projet à 250
millions d'euros débuté en 2010 la
rénovation du centre commercial parly ii
implantée aux chaînés depuis 1969 et
dans sa dernière phase 180 ouvriers
travaillent actuellement sur une liaison
de 10 mille mètres carrés qui permettra
une circulation boucle dans le centre et
d'accueillir des magasins
supplémentaires derrière nous il y aura
un grand rectangle à qui accueillera sur
deux niveaux l'extension du monoprix est
aussi une cellule pour accueillir la
poissonnerie et derrière dans l'angle la
partie longue duel se trouvera donc
cette connexion entre deux partis du
centre avec ses quinze enseignes
supplémentaires
le lifting s'opère également à
l'extérieur du centre commercial les
façades extérieures construite au siècle
dernier sont actuellement en cours de
restauration
les façades seront bien commencer à vous
aurez un aperçu au niveau de la façade
du bhv c'est à la fois un alliance des
motifs historiques de panneaux qu'on
appelle les moucharabiehs il y a aussi
des plaques de mbk en céramique sur les
façades principales et enfin sur
certains angles un habillage en pierre
de vals grise bleue pour habiller les
façades notamment côté voie publique
avec ces travaux la structure qui attire
déjà 12 millions de visiteurs par an
espère en accueillir 3 millions de plus
à l'horizon 2018
redonnez en fait à paris de son
rayonnement régional
et à les capter une clientèle alors de
paris 16ème en passant par saint germain
en laye jouy en josas montfort l'amaury
pas à pas une concurrence notamment
renforcé avec un beau grenelle 1 vélizy
un plaisir à saint germain en laye donc
voilà fort de cette rénovation des
parties communes des parties extérieures
des façades et cette offre
supplémentaire de 15 en scène
supplémentaire
on est vraiment un mais pour les
prochaines décennies l'inauguration
officielle est programmée pour la fin
novembre par les 2 proposera à partir de
cette date 117 mille mètres carrés de
surfaces commerciales et plus de 200
magasins à deux ans de fêter ses
cinquante ans mardi dans notre émission
7,8 les invités nous recevions
jean-claude jamot le président du comité
départemental de la randonnée pédestre
celui ci nous a présenté l'opération
rando net qui vise à nettoyer les
chemins et les sentiers du département
lors de plusieurs marches organisées
tout le long du mois d'avril
extraits de cet entretien et nous ne
troll il est pédagogique justement on se
promène avec nos sacs sur lesquels il ya
vraiment la spécificité de ce que l'on
fait et donc on en profite pour parler
aux gens que l'on rencontre
je crois qu'il n'y a que comme ça qu'on
peut arriver à vraiment interpellé les
gens d'ailleurs c'est pas uniquement les
membres de votre de vos clubs qui
peuvent partir en paix à randonner tout
le monde peut y participer là tout le
monde et il ya beaucoup de municipalités
qui commence à vouloir s'accrocher à
notre système si vous voulez et pour
participer aussi à la propreté générale
lors ce qui est important c'est que les
sacs on ramène les détritus et on les
trie on les ramène d'ailleurs chaque
personne les ramène chez elle et fait le
tri donc c'est vraiment un processus
clean nos sacs sont en amidon de maïs
bio dégradable on laisse aucune casse du
sport à présent un tournoi unss de
handball était organisée ce mercredi 19
avril à plaisir le lycée jean vilar de
la commune a notamment affronté un lycée
de l'académie de paris et un autre de
créteil l'école est une habituée de ce
tournoi puisqu'elle s'est déjà qualifiée
en 2012 pour les championnats de france
alors at elle réalisé une nouvelle fois
l exploit la réponse avec ce reportage
de michael
d'euros le titre de champion inter
académique de handball s'est joué ce
mercredi 19 avril à plaisir
l'association sportive du lycée jean
vilar recevait au gymnase de nicholas
l'heure les lycées de paris et de
montereau objectif décrocher une
qualification pour les championnats de
france unss
douze élèves plaisir wa actuellement en
seconde et en première ont participé à
la compétition
ok là le niveau il est moins élevé qu'en
club quand même mais il reste quand même
bon sur l'équipe de paris nous sommes on
est un peu au dessus physiquement aussi
mais sinon après ces attaques il s'agit
bien c'est assez important quand même
même si c'est un championnat qui est
moins fort que ce qu'on pratique en club
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on tient à
coeur parce qu'on est des compétiteurs
et on veut absolument gagner ce tournoi
est aussi l'occasion de mettre en
pratique les deux heures de cours
dispensées chaque mercredi depuis début
septembre où dans le lycée moi je suis
dans le questionnement je les fait
réfléchir sur le jeu je les fais
intervenir dans les temps morts
je les fais intervenir à la mi temps
pour avoir leurs ressentis savoir ce
qu'il faut changer et cetera sais pas
c'est pas moi qui donne toutes les
informations j'essaie de les mobiliser à
l'heure au sens tactique et réfléchie du
jeu pour que y ait un vrai apprentissage
pas l'équipe de plaisir a finalement
terminé deuxième après sa défaite 23 9
contre le lycée montereau un classement
qui leur permet d'accéder au championnat
de france unss
la compétition devrait se dérouler fin
mai image assez la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo merci de nous avoir suivis
retrouvez tous nos reportages en replay
sur tv fil 78 ou l'application tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bon week-end à tous pensé bien sûr à
aller voter et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour